I'm gonna say this right now I apologize
for my behavior when I came in number
one I'm sick number two I had to carry
four gigantic bags and then a litter
that like my arms are like completely
tore off I understand that but I want to
do myself because I'm man and number
three was a three yet three yeah I'm
gonna go to - okay I wanna make it -
okay and number two right I came in here
and I said hey can you help me put the
stuff away because the cat food and all
the treats that I bought
googy and everyone they get into it I'm
gonna hide all that stuff and it came in
and III think that's my bad I apologized
and I want everyone to forgive me now I
apologize
I don't feel well i forgiven you okay
strangely enough yeah you know you
wouldn't strike me normally as a guy who
is like a gentleman like yeah normally
right from afar from what people hear
you would probably assume that Bobby is
somebody who lets everybody do
everything for him but he will never let
me carry a grocery bag never let me
carry my own luggage he really is a man
in that way I want how nice well she's
he always I mean even when he's
struggling fantastic
keep going class what he even when he's
struggling and I offer and he's pissed
he's pissed at the weight he has to
carry he insists on carrying it because
I still want to be a man
[Music]